so it is very unusual that we see a
director stick with a franchise and be
able to close out a trilogy like this
particularly with animated movies so I
was wondering along the way was there
ever even a thought in your mind to kind
of step back and hand the reins over or
did you know from day one that this was
your series well not from day one so I
was brought on in the project along with
Chris Sanders when we had 15 months
before the release of the first film and
it needed a story departure a fairly
significant one so that was a rush to
the end we weren't thinking about a any
sequels or a trilogy it was only after
the film went out there and made some
money for the studio and it was well
received but they said okay how about a
sequel and I'm generally like allergic
to sequels to be honest so I said unless
it has purpose unless unless there's a
you know a larger mission to this and I
thought well we have a lot of unanswered
questions in the first movie and the
idea of the book series even though we
didn't necessarily follow the narrative
was to follow hiccup from kind of Viking
run to narrow do well two wise selfless
Viking chief by the end of it and so
there seemed to be an opportunity let's
do three acts of one story independent
movies that wouldn't rely upon
necessarily the having seen the previous
one so they weren't cliffhangers but the
idea of doing three movies meant a
commitment of at least you know eight to
ten years but I thought at the end of
the day I'd be really cool because I
grew up a Star Wars kid anyone who Star
Wars kid two understands the idea of
when you fall in love with something
it's not just a movie that you go and
see you and you enjoy it becomes a part
of you and I feel like this franchise
had that effect on people too yeah you
know and I think I'm one of those I'm
one of those kids who just loved stories
where you had young protagonists in over
their heads in a world of supernatural
or fantasy what got me with this always
was the Pet Connection I even though I
couldn't identify with everything hiccup
was going through it's that relationship
with him and toothless that always
really spoke to me and one of the things
I've always enjoyed reading about in
terms of making of these movies is when
you use specific animals for influences
with the designs and also their movement
and it made me curious was there any
animal that you tried to incorporate in
that way that either just didn't work or
you never got the opportunity to do mmm
well I think we certainly had to expand
upon Vulcans dragon cloud jumper the
initial inspiration was an owl but
beyond turning their heads nearly
completely around there's not a whole
lot that owls do is offset blinking so
we had to come up with a lot more
personality for that dragon even though
the that was the initial starting place
and how about the animation technology
because I feel like in the past year in
particular we've kind of seen the
animation industry explode in so many
wonderful ways so is there any piece of
text that we could see being used in
hidden world that you never had access
to before yes we have a back back-end
system a back-end renderer which allows
us to not only create light that looks
very real because it actually calculates
light rays from the source and how it
bounces off of you know some floors and
surfaces and affects skin so that
allowed Roger Deakins and our our visual
effects supervisor devolver to work
really closely on creating like this
visceral kind of palpable credible
lighting look for our movie but it's
also very very fast and so it allowed us
to realize ambition scope and scale that
we weren't able to take on before is so
undervalued in animated films and it
always catches my eye but jumping off of
that I was wondering we know you we know
the voice actors who lead these movies
but is there anyone who would call the
unsung hero of the How to Train Your
Dragon franchise that you want to make
sure the name gets out there and people
know their hard work well I would hope
that people know of John Towell
if they don't they really should he's a
he's a master composer
and for me music is half of the equation
it does all the heavy lifting it does it
speaks to the heart and ways that
dialogue can never do and I rely upon
him so heavily to just lift the movie to
shape it to bring tonal harmony to it
and thematic relevance and so he is he's
very modest and he likes to sit it out
in the background but I would love to
shine a spotlight on him
[Music]